[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Barbara
hweg guten Abend ihnen allen Norbert
Lehmann ist auch dabei für den Sport
schön guten Abend von mir die Ampel
versucht den
Befreiungsschlag ein Nachtragshaushalt
soll es richten Finanzminister Lindner
will jetzt die Schuldenbremse lösen
nimmt das Wort aber nicht in den
Mund rechts außen bei der Parlamentswahl
in den Niederlanden holt Gert Wilders
die meisten Stimmen vor allem wegen
seiner scharfen Kritik an Zuwanderung
und
Islam Gewalt auf Straßen und Plätzen die
Zahl der Fälle in Deutschland steigt
besonders deutlich bei jungen Menschen
[Musik]
überraschender Kurzauftritt des
Finanzministers heute als Konsequenz aus
dem Urteil des
Bundesverfassungsgerichts werde er
kommende Woche einen nachtragshaus alt
fürs laufende Jahr vorlegen heißt um die
entstandenen Milliardenlöcher zu stopfen
will die Bundesregierung nun doch die im
Grundgesetz verankerte Schuldenbremse
aussetzen das hatte die FDP eigentlich
abgelehnt Daniel
ponzen der Auftritt des Finanzministers
auf dem Podium dauerte exakt 76 Sekunden
eine Kernbotschaft brachte er darin
unter eine zweite lieferte eine
Sprecherin kurz darauf
nach Abs mit dem Bundeskanzler und dem
Vizekanzler werde ich in der nächsten
Woche einen Nachtragshaushalt für dieses
Jahr vorlegen wir werden die Ausgaben äh
insbesondere für die Strom- und
gaspreisbremse jetzt auf eine
verfassungsrechtlich gesicherte
Grundlage stellen dazu bedarf es dieses
Nachtragshaushaltes dazu wiederum bedarf
es und dies wurde schriftlich
nachgereicht der Feststellung einer
außergewöhnlichen Notlage für das das
Jahr 2023 um die Schuldenbremse
nachträglich doch noch einmal
auszusetzen diese Feststellung werde die
Bundesregierung dem Bundestag
vorschlagen der chefhaushälter der SPD
ergänzte am Abend die Erwartung auch den
Haushalt 24 noch in diesem Jahr
abschließend zu beraten mit dem
Nachtragshaushalt mache sich die Ampel
endlich ehrlich lobt die Union die
geklagt hatte das schwierigste aber
stehe noch bevor schmerzhafte
Einsparungen einer der Punkte die wir
konkret ansprechen ist das Thema
Bürgergeld wir haben 4 Millionen
erwerbsfähige also Menschen die arbeiten
könnten im Bürgergeld wenn nur eine
Million davon in Arbeit gebracht würde
würde das den Bundeshaushalt
Bundeshaushalt um 30 Milliarden jedes
Jahr entlasten da hätten wir viel Geld
für Investitionen zur Verfügung sehr
große Einsparungen in sehr kurzer Zeit
für die Ampel wird es eine neuerliche
vielleicht die schwerste
Belastungsprobe ja was war das heute
shakunta Laer in Berlin der Versuch
eines be
frereiungsschlags also für einen
Befreiungsschlag war das heute gemessen
an der Gesamtaufgabe ein zu kleiner
Schritt Christian Lindner hat ja jetzt
vor allem mal angekündigt wie der
Lösungsweg für den Haushalt 23
aussehen kann das hat da für etwas mehr
Klarheit gesorgt in der ganzen
Gemengelage aber der nächste Schritt
wird der ganz schwierige das ist der
Haushalt für das Jahr 2024 und daran
dass Christian Lindner von
Schuldenbremse in seinem Statement nicht
einmal sprechen wollte kann man glaube
ich ablesen wie schwer sich die FDP
damit tut dieses Thema zu besprechen und
auch beim Haushalt 2024 wird es in der
Ampel wieder um die Frage gehen wie wird
das Ganze finanziert aus mehr Schulden
mit noch einer Aussetzung der
Schuldenbremse oder durch mehr sparen
also da geht die ganze Diskussion dann
wieder von vorne los es ist etwas mehr
Klarheit geschaffen worden heute aber
die Ampel ist noch nicht raus aus der
Misere mit diesem Schritt danke schön
für diese Einordnung aus der Hauptstadt
chakunta La benaner war das die
haushaltskr überlagert natürlich auch
den Parteitag der Grünen keiner weiß was
von ihren Klimaschutzprojekten noch
finanzierbar ist zudem murd die Basis
dass die Grünen in der Regierung immer
weiter einknicken würden und die
Umfragewerte sind auch schwach nicht die
beste Rampe für das Treffen in Karlsruhe
vor zwei Stunden ging es los Andreas
Huppert und Patrizia Wiedemeier sind
dabei machen was zählt das offizielle
Motto des Parteitages machen was
überhaupt noch bezahlbar ist würde eher
passen die Haushaltskrise der Ampel die
fehlenden 60 Milliarden auch hier das
beherrschende Thema dass der
Finanzminister kurz zuvor verkündet hat
die Schuldenbremse zumindest für dieses
Jahr auszusetzen sorgt für Erleichterung
und Diskussionsbedarf wir werden darüber
reden was es für uns heißt in dieser
Regierung zu sein was es heißt vor den
Herausforderungen dieser Zeit zu stehen
und was wir für die Menschen in diesem
Land für unsere Wirtschaft für den
Klimaschutz tun wollen und können
darüber werden wir diskutieren für die
Grünen ist klar Klimaschutz und der
Umbau der Wirtschaft haben Vorrang nicht
nur zeitweise sondern soangee wie nötig
eines ist klar wenn wir jetzt nicht
investieren wenn wir jetzt nicht die
Wirtschaft modernisieren dann fallen wir
auch im internationalen Wettbewerb
zurück und das kann niemand wollen es
wird sehr viel teurer werden wenn wir
diese Investition nicht tätigen und
dagegen sind wahrscheinlich 60
Milliarden in klack auch die Sicherheit
Deutschlands gebe es nicht zum
Nulltarif wir brauchen dringend Geld um
auf der einen Seite die Bundeswehr
vernün aufzustellen nämlich hart
ausgedrückt die Schuldenbremse wird
Putin nicht aufhalten beim Thema
Finanzen sind sich Parteispitze und
Grüne Basis erstaunlich einig die
Botschaft von hier ist klar
Schuldenbremse aussetzen und nachhaltig
investieren nicht nur im Jahre 2023
sondern auch in all den kommenden Jahren
der auftagt in Karlsruhe harmonisch doch
spätestens Samstagabend könnte es damit
vorbei sein dann stehen die Themen Asyl
und Zuwanderung auf der Tagesordnung
das haushaltsurteil des
Bundesverfassungsgerichts hat auch
Auswirkungen auf die Länder mit breiter
Mehrheit hat der Kieler Landtag eine
Haushaltsnotlage für schlesäwig-
Holstein festgestellt fürs laufende und
fürs kommende Jahr die schwarzgrüne
Koalition begründete ihr Vorgehen mit
mehreren gleichzeitigen Krisen ähnlich
wie die Bundesregierung hatte auch die
Koalition in Kiel Kredite aus der
coronapandemie
umgewidmet
jetzt zum politischen Erdbeben in den
Niederlanden die Wahl gestern hat ein
Islam feindlicher Rechtsaußen gewonnen
Gert will das zum Regieren ist seine
Partei alleine aber zu schwach sie hat
37 von 150 Parlamentssitzen auf Platz 2
das rotgrüne Bündnis von Franz timmermnz
mit 25 sitzen die bisher Regierenden
Rechtsliberalen mit ihrer Chefin dyan
jeschel Göss liegen bei 24 und der
frühere Christ Demokrat Peter omzicht
mit seiner neuen Partei bekommt 20 Sitze
die übrigen Mandate verteilen sich auf
mehr als 10 weitere Parteien Ulf röer
berichtet der Rechtspopulist Gert
Wilders feiert am Morgen mit Champagner
aus Frankreich einen Sieg in den
Niederlanden auf die Niederlande stoßen
wir an die Wahl ein Triumph für seine
Ziele die die Niederlande radikal
verändern würden denn will das es ein
knallharter
er zweifelt an der EU und der NATO er
will den Islam verbannen und will das
Recht auf Asyl
abschaffen ich werde dafür sorgen dass
die Niederlande wieder den Niederländern
gehören dass der asylzunami begrenzt
wird wilders hat sich im Wahlkampf
handzam gegeben aber die Liste der
Gratulanten zeigt die Bedeutung seines
Sieges für die Rechtspopulisten in
Europa die Französin Le Pen und die
deutsche alles Weidel gratulieren der
Rechtsruck bewegt viele wir kennen wild
das Ziele ich mache mir
sorgen wir müssen lernen mit den
Ergebnis zu
leben wild das braucht aber Partner die
unterlegenen Rechtsliberalen haben vor
der Wahl eine Koalition mit Wilders
nicht ausgeschlossen das gilt auch nach
der Wahl dafür wird die
Spitzenkandidatin kritisiert sie hätte
so wild wählbar
gemacht s der Grund für den Erfolg wir
haben zu lange diese Sorgen
ignoriert Franz timmermn ist der
Hoffnungsträger für alle die nicht will
das wollen sein Bündnis aus
Sozialdemokraten und Grünen ist auf
Platz 2 gelandet er wirbt für eine
antiilders
Koalition unsere Aufgabe ist jetzt für
eine niederlander einzustehen die
niemanden
acheen dauern bis klar ist wer die
Niederlande
regiert fragen wir nach bei gun Krüger
in den Hag welche Chancen hat will das
tatsächlich Regierungschef zu
werden diese Chancen stehen gar nicht so
schlecht erstaunlich war ja die Höhe des
Wahlsiegs den Wilders eingefahren hat
nicht so sehr erstaunen sollte der
Pragmatismus mit dem sich jetzt
Politiker hier in den Hag an dieses
Ergebnis ransetzen vor der Wahl hatten
zwei der Partner die auf je Fall für ein
Bündnis braucht gesagt will das achte
bestimmte Grundrechte nicht will das
werde man nie zum premier wählen diese
Schwüre die hört man nun nach der Wahl
seit gestern nicht mehr stattdessen
heißt es es sei ein schweres Puzzle man
werde sich aber ransetzen man wird sich
sicherlich einig bei Themen wie den
Bauern und den Stickstoff und vor allem
bei dem großen wahlthema Migration
schwieriger wird es wahrscheinlich eine
Einigung zu erzielen bei Themen wie der
Unterstützung der Ukraine mit Waffen
oder der Zusammenarbeit in der EU wild
das hat da seine radikalsten Positionen
geräumt aber trotzdem egal in welcher in
welcher Formation er an dieser Regierung
beteiligt werden sollte für die EU und
für Deutschland werden die Niederlande
in Zukunft sicherlich ein unbequemerer
Partner gun Krüger live aus den Hag
vielen
Dank zum Krieg in N Ost eigentlich
sollten heute mehrere Geiseln freikommen
Menschen die seit 48 Tagen in der Hand
der Terrororganisation Hamas sind doch
das wurde verschoben morgen Nachmittag
soll der Austausch gegen
palästinensische Gefängnis in sassen nun
tatsächlich beginnen sagt der Vermittler
Katar und es gebe eine Feuerpause ab
morgen früh Dominik
lmeister sie gehen unvermindert weiter
die Kämpfe in Gazastreifen nach
palästinensischen Angaben sein 15
Menschen bei israelischen Luftangriffen
getötet worden unabhängig überprüfen
lässt sich das nicht keine Feuerpause
keine geiselfreilassung bisher israels
Ministerpräsident hofft bei einem
Treffen mit Großbritanniens neuen
Außenminister dass die Vereinbarung bald
Realität wird es ist nicht ohne
Herausforderungen aber wir müssen hoffen
dass wir die erste Gruppe herausbringen
können wir wollen alle
herausholen die Angehörigen der Geiseln
in Israel sind enttäuscht sie hoffen
dass die ersten Freilassungen bald
stattfinden es war zu erwarten dass so
etwas passieren wird in Verhandlungen
passieren solche Sachen egal von welcher
Seite es verursacht wurde dann warten
wir noch einen Tag Vermittler Qatar hat
inzwischen angekündigt die Feuerpause
werde morgen um 6 Uhr deutscher Zeit
beginnen dann werde die Hamas auch die
erste Gruppe von 13 Frauen und Kindern
freilassen das wird ungefähr um 16 Uhr
Ortszeit passieren jeden Tag wird es ein
Zeitfenster geben die Situation wird
dann sicherer für die Geiseln sein sie
werden dann dem Roten Kreuz
übergeben auch die notleidende
Zivilbevölkerung im Gazastreifen wartet
darauf dass die Vereinbarung zwischen
Israel und der Hamas Wirklichkeit wird
erst dann sind größere Hilfslieferungen
möglich vor 3 Wochen hat Innenministerin
Feser die islamistische Hamas und das
palästinensische Netzwerk samidun
verboten jetzt sind 16 Wohnungen und
Räume mutmaßlicher Anhänger in mehreren
Bundesländern durchsucht worden
Schwerpunkt der razja war Berlin 350
Polizisten waren allein dort im Einsatz
Durchsuchungen gab es auch in
Niedersachsen Nordrhein-Westfalen und
Schleswig-Holstein beunruhigende Zahlen
kommen von der Herbsttagung des
Bundeskriminalamts bei
Gewaltkriminalität erfasste die Polizei
in der ersten Jahreshälfte 17% mehr
Fälle als im
Vorjahreszeitraum vor allem im
öffentlichen Raum also auf Straßen und
Plätzen nahmen die Delikte zu
alarmierend dabei ist dass immer mehr
Kinder und Jugendliche gewalttätig
werden Isabel de
lawega Ausschreitungen bei proalästina
Demonstrationen prügelein mit der
Polizei auf Eritrea Festivals ein
tödlicher Messerangriff in einem
Fitnessstudio in Duisburg gegen
extremistische Gewalttaten will die
bundesinnenministerin heute auf der
Herbsttagung des Bundeskriminalamtes mit
Härte vorgehen
wir gehen sehr stark gegen islamistische
Hetze auf den Straßen vor wir haben
vereinsverbote ausgesprochen wir haben
zahlreiche Durchsuchungsmaßnahmen gerade
heute wieder insofern ist der
Rechtsstaat am Handeln die Gewalttaten
von Ausländern sind in Deutschland
deutlich gestiegen das liegt an der
höheren Zahl von Flüchtlingen neben der
Migration ist auch die erhöhte Mobilität
nach covidingrund es bieten sich wieder
mehr tatgelegenheiten im öffentlichen
Raum außerdem spielen die Inflation und
die wirtschaftliche vieler eine Rolle
was wir erst mal sagen können ist dass
die
Gewaltkriminalität stärker steigt als
das statistisch erwartbar gewesen wäre
mit 17% in diesem Jahr nach 20% im
letzten Jahr auffallend in der
Kriminalitätsstatistik ist auch die
zunehmende Gewalt durch Kinder und
Jugendliche für Experten hat das noch
immer mit der Pandemie zu tun ich
beobachte eine massive Defizite in der
Empathie Entwicklung das hat zu tun dass
diese Menschen in den letzten
Jahren massiv
in digitalen Welten unterwegs waren ohne
Kontrolle insgesamt müsse viel mehr in
Prävention investiert
werden dazu passt noch eine
erschütternde Statistik zur Gewalt gegen
Frauen nach Angaben der Vereinten
Nationen wurden
2022 weltweit so viele Frauen ermordet
wie seit 20 Jahren nicht mehr und 89000
Frauen und Mädchen sein absichtlich
getötet worden heißt es in dem Bericht
besonders alarmierend sei bei
55% war der Täter ein Partner oder ein
Familienmitglied im Norden Chinas sind
offenbar ungewöhnlich viele Kinder an
einer Lungenentzündung erkrankt die
Weltgesundheitsorganisation hat China
nun aufgefordert zusätzliche
Informationen zu liefern z.B über die
Ausbreitung oder
Laborergebnisse auch in Peking drängen
sich viele Menschen in einer
Kinderklinik China erklärte die Zunahme
der Infektionen mit der Aufhebung vieler
coronamaßnahmen dadurch hätten sich die
Erreger verbreiten
können Zivil courourage im Alltag was
Menschen da immer wieder vollbringen
zeigt der XY Preis gemeinsam gegen das
Verbrechen heute wurde er in Berlin
verliehen Innenministerin fäer
bezeichnete die vier Preisträger und
Preisträgerinnen als Vorbilder
ausgezeichnet wurde auch der 40-Jährige
Mohammad alhassan aus Mülheim an der
Ruhe der gebürtige syer überwältigte
einen bewaffneten Mann der eine
81-jährige niedergestochen
hatte und jetzt zur Fußball Champions
League da haben die Frankfurterinnen die
Sensation verpasst noch ja im
Gruppenspiel gegen den Titelverteidiger
den FC Barcelona die Eintracht ging mit
einer 1:0 Führung in die Pause doch dann
in Halbzeit 2 da schlugen die katalanin
eiskalt zu Laura freigangsfreude über
den Führungstreffer gegen das beste
vereinsteam der Welt wirkt ansteckend
kurz vor der Pause erzielt die
Nationalspielerin nach brillanter Flanke
von Verena hchoders 1:0 fast zu schön um
wahr zu sein ich kam in die Pause und
ich dachte so was passiert hier gerade
kN mich jemand aber dann weiß man es
geht halt noch 45 Minuten und ist
Barcelona tatsächlich drehen die
Titelverteidigerinnen in der zweiten
Hälfte auf Salma ganz knapp V Johannes
zum Ausgleich nach einem Fehler der
Frankfurter torhütterin das 2:1 durch
mariona und in der 62 Minute trifft
erneut Weltmeisterin Salma 3:1 Barcelona
das geschlagene Team von Trainer
annautis ist dennoch mit guten Chancen
die Champions League Gruppenphase zu
überstehen ja und jetzt zu den
fußballmännern nach den beiden
Niederlagen des dfbteams kieren auch
einige gefrustete Bayernspieler in den
Bundesliga Alltag zurück der zweite von
oben in der Tabelle trifft morgen abend
auswärt auf den zweiten von unten den
ersten fC
Köln traurige dfbsieler sollen der
Vergangenheit angehören Thomas Tuchel
möchte einen Stimmungswechsel wir
versuchen eher ein Umfeld zu geben in
dem sich die Spieler wohlfühlen positiv
sein können auch wenn es nicht so lief
wie sich es alle gewünscht haben an die
letzte Reise in die Domstadt haben
einige Spieler noch sehr gute
Erinnerungen im Mai machte man im
Saisonfinale hier die Meisterschaft klar
jetzt wartet eine andere Partie Köln
Tabellen Vorletzter aber extrem
motiviert die Bayern zu schlagen der
Matchplan von Steffen Baumgart
steht am Ende geht's darum mutig zu
agieren und zu gucken dass du bei dir
bleibst und versuchst natürlich dann
deine Stärken auf dem Platz zu kriegen
zuletzt gelang 2011 ein Sieg gegen den
Rekordmeister vielleicht klappt es ja
diesen Freitag die Bayern zu
ärgern jawohl schauen wir mal mutig
agieren und gucken dass du bei dir
bleibst das wird unsere Losung für die
weiteren Tage der Winter ist im Anmarsch
auf Regen und Sturm Folgen Glätte und
Schnee Einzelheiten gleich von Katja
horneffer um : Uhr spricht Marietta
slomker im heute journal mit der grünen
kchefin Ricarda lang und hier übernimmt
morgen Mitri Sirin Ihnen alles Gute und
auf
[Musik]
bald guten Abend jetzt wird es ist
winterlich erstmal ist eine Kaltfront
herangekommen bis heute abend hat sie
ungefähr die Nord und ostseküste
erreicht und in der Nacht zieht sie
weiter südwärts und da kann es in den
Mittelgebirgen und auch am Alpenrand
schon mal ein bisschen Schnee geben am
längsten trocken bleibt es wohl hier im
Südwesten Deutschlands und dazu pfeift
ein starker bis stürmischer Wind aus
westlichen bis nordwestlichen Richtungen
an der Küste erwarten wir schwere
sturmböhen im Erzgebirge stürmische
böhnen und in den Gipfellagen der
Mittelgebirge sind auch orkanböhnen
möglich dieser kräftige Wind durchmischt
die Luft die bleibt deswegen relativ
mild in dieser Nacht mit 7 bis 2° und
nur am windschwachen Alpenrand geht's in
den leichten Frost von -1° morgen liegen
die Höchsttemperaturen zwischen 5 und 9°
und zwischen der Ostseeküste und den
Mittelgebirgen sind es nur so 3 bis 5°
und morgen gibt es weitere kräftige
Regen Schneeregen und Graupelschauer zum
Teil könnte durchaus mal ein
graupelgewitter dabei sein zwischendurch
werden sie auch die Sonne zu Gesicht
bekommen und der Wind ist immer noch
kräftig aber nicht mehr ganz so stark
wie in der kommenden Nacht und es geht
winterlich weiter am freundlichsten wird
es am Wochenende in Norddeutschland sein
und am Montag liegen die
Höchsttemperaturen nur noch bei -1 bis +
6° guten Abend